corrupción malversación de fondos
públicos alianzas entre autoridades y
Bandas criminales y también minería
ilegal las investigaciones de Rafael
Moreno dejaron en evidencia múltiples
casos ahora que han comenzado a
profundizar y que ya van a dar a conocer
estas investigaciones qué es lo que han
encontrado
Buenas noches Muchas gracias por la
invitación la lo que hemos encontrado es
que Rafael Moreno tenía razón Y pues si
bien no hay un avance significativo en
la investigación penal que se sigue por
su homicidio pues sabemos que las
denuncias que la hacía sobre corrupción
en el sur de Córdoba no eran infundadas
tenían todas las evidencias del mundo y
tal vez
por por lo alejado que le estaba de
centros urbanos por lo aislado que
estaba de grandes medios de comunicación
de pronto no tenía las herramientas que
logramos tener nosotros
al trabajar como consorcio 30
periodistas para descubrir y corroborar
Pues muchas de sus denuncias y pongo un
ejemplo muy concreto Claro en una de las
publicaciones que sacamos mañana vamos a
revelar imágenes satelitales que desde
luego Rafael Moreno desde Córdoba no
hubiera podido acceder a ellos
Felipe qué sigue entonces ahora quién
responde en un país como Colombia en
donde la institucionalidad siempre están
en entredicho y pues se puede decir que
la justicia es selectiva
Sí pues es un caso muy triste porque ya
han pasado seis meses desde el asesinato
de Rafael Moreno y a pesar de que
supuestamente es un caso priorizado por
la fiscalía general no ha habido ni
siquiera una captura
conocemos desde octubre el video de en
el que se ve a la persona que le disparó
y ni siquiera esa persona ha sido
capturada esperamos Pues que que por lo
menos los asesinos de Rafael entiendan
que se equivocaron si pensaron que que
lo iban a poder silenciar y que
definitivamente esa frase que nos dijo
Rafael si me van a matar mátenme pero no
me van a silenciar pues o este 18 de
abril se cumple
Felipe esta plataforma que estábamos
mencionando acá forbidden Stories y sus
medios asociados son cerca de 30 a nivel
mundial que ha permitido que estas
investigaciones Pues llegaran a Puerto
que se puede decir de esta plataforma de
la misión y de esta iniciativa a nivel
internacional para protegerla a los
periodistas que en el caso de Rafael
pues perdieron la vida otros que son
perseguidos o simplemente silenciados
sí por vía Stories nace con la misión de
de continuar el trabajo de periodistas
amenazados o asesinados en el caso de
Rafael es el primer caso que llega por
vía Stories en el que el periodista
llegó a contactarlos antes de ser
asesinado y él hablando con ellos en
octubre particularmente el 7 de octubre
de 2022 les dijo Yo quiero que ustedes
continúen con mis investigaciones si
algo llegara a pasarme diez once días
después el 16 de octubre lo lo Asesinan
y por eso es que por bien Story toma la
decisión de de continuar con el trabajo
de Rafael partiendo de una información
que ella les había compartido Entonces
es una es una manera también de decirles
a los enemigos de la libertad de
expresión y a las personas que siguen
pensando que asesinar periodistas Pues
es rentable políticamente de alguna
manera que no lo Es que desde luego las
agresiones a la prensa no acallan las
denuncias y que aquí estaremos
pues más periodistas sumándonos a a
seguir el trabajo de estos periodistas
que pueden estar solos en las regiones
pero que no están solos en su ejercicio
periodístico